[Music]
thank you to brilliant for supporting
PBS Digital Studios our hold it good job
ok now let's get a brooding one what's
this
Oh Basil's headshots headshots yeah I
mean I thought about how much money we
put into this little guy we don't get
anything in return except love and
companionship there's no reason he
shouldn't start pulling his own weight
so I made a list of all the jobs basil
could do you know like sheepdog guard
dog firefighter but I decided on
internet celebrity is there money in
that
how are you kidding boo the Pomeranian
makes a million a year from book deals
and endorsements and grumpy cats net
worth is estimated at over a hundred
million dollars cool we're gonna need a
couple more for nails in here maybe a
softbox how we feelin about costumes
[Music]
cats and dogs have been friends with
humanity for tens of thousands of years
and in the early days the relationship
was mutually beneficial the animals got
a safer life with plenty of scraps to
eat in exchange for keeping predators
and vermin away from our homes today
it's much more of a one-way street
Americans spend more than sixty billion
dollars a year on our furry friends
without getting any obvious financial
return on that investment and according
to one survey 98% of cat and dog owners
significantly underestimated the
lifetime cost of their pet the majority
thought it would be less than $6,500 and
twelve percent expected to pay less than
$650 for the pets entire life these
people know that animals need food right
so how much does it cost to own a pet
well the ASPCA estimates that the
average lifetime cost is around fifteen
thousand for dogs and 12,500 for cats
and that doesn't even include things
like property damage or boarding a more
expansive study in the UK put the
numbers even higher that may sound
surprising but it makes sense once you
start itemizing take the average owner
of a mid-sized dog after the initial
costs of adoptions baying and neutering
and purchases like crates and bowls he
or she can expect outlays for food
medical bills grooming toys and treats
that total on average about 47 dollars a
month they'll spend about 500 a year in
boarding and dog sitting and almost 400
a year replacing damaged property like
shoes sofas and doors that's an annual
cost of about one thousand four hundred
sixty dollars if the dog lives an
average of twelve years that's a
lifetime cost of about eighteen thousand
dollars and that doesn't even include
any money for emergency medical visits
most people considering a new pet
probably don't think of it as being as
expensive as a new car or a down payment
on a house
hmm maybe basil doesn't have what it
takes to be a celebrity we should have
started him earlier mm-hmm well even if
your pet doesn't technically work for
its living it doesn't mean you aren't
getting some kind of financial return on
investment like home security
many people consider dog ownership to be
a more effective crime deterrent than
burglar alarms which average $1,000 for
installation and $30 a month and then
there's your health many studies have
found a relationship between pet
ownership and improved mental and
physical well-being people who own a dog
or cat tend to make fewer visits to the
doctor and have lower rates of
depression children who grow up with
animals in the house tend to have
stronger immune systems making them less
susceptible to viruses and allergies and
seniors who care for pets actually tend
to live longer than those who don't but
that doesn't mean you can't still be
cost conscious you can save hundreds of
dollars right off the bat by adopting an
animal rather than buying one from a pet
store or a breeder
not only are you helping alleviate the
widespread problem of animal
homelessness but shelter dogs and cats
tend to have fewer health problems and
if you want animal companionship without
the financial commitment you could
possibly volunteer to foster an animal
in your home not only will the shelter
pay its medical costs but some of your
other expenses may be tax-deductible
some people purchase pet health
insurance as a way to cut down on
medical costs but most plans will not
save you money on routine vet bills just
rare procedures like surgery and if you
have a purebred dog many plans will
specifically not cover the conditions
your breed is prone to Philip and I
preferred keep an emergency fund is that
aside for any unexpected medical costs
that way we know we don't have to choose
between treatment and staying out of
debt none of this is to say that you
should feel bad about spending money on
your pets our pets make us happy and
happiness is a good reason to spend
money but keeping track of how much
you're spending will help you make
better financial plans for the whole
family and in the off chance your pupper
does become an Instagram star you'll
know exactly how much to bill them for
plus interest and that's our two cents
thank you to brilliant for supporting
PBS Digital Studios
are you excited to apply the concepts
you've learned on to sense but
confidence when it comes to your math or
science skills you could try brilliant
org for that brilliant org is a hands-on
way to strengthen those number crunching
muscles from algebra to calculus logic
to probability it's a fun way to develop
a confidence and ease with numbers
science and more you can learn more at
brilliant org slash two cents
[Music]